[Music]
good morning everyone
and yeah my name is Sergey this is Adam
and eight of me today and it will speak
about my cycle problem so probably many
of you attended yesterday at a gift talk
where he introduced new architecture
components he introduced like that have
your own new persistence live renamed
room and today we will focus on life
cycle part of this architectural
components so we will stick again about
like that energy model we will stick
about life cycle owners and the check
events that are basis for this libraries
but we will have more details we will
have some reasoning behind our decisions
so if you attended yesterday it's really
still interesting if you did it at end
yesterday we will reintroduce all of the
things so you're going to send
everything and so let's see what we have
today and today we have a in activity a
fragment or starter has led not for line
length but dozens and dozens line of
light lines and this lines are results
of very natural process like Google Play
services ask you to register them in all
start methods your own components need
to know about its lifecycle events so
you need to forward them in some kind of
API and correspondingly and on stock
method you have to call all pairing
stock methods and it's very easy to
forget one and this will result in sub
feedback it will drain a users battery
and they will enjoy your app a bit less
which is probably helpful for them but
you think that's bad and I think that
answer on this situation is introduced
by cycle aware components so components
which handle life cycle and the first
step in this direction is to introduce
life cycle the first class citizen so
it's a very simple of which answer you
question what is the current state right
now and notify you about new events and
then note which is important but sounds
ridiculous right now
events and states are different things
so let's see what I mean your case is it
associated in initialized state and all
creation phases
fans very recently on create created
state i'll start started state same
thing for resume but the row down is
between more interesting so on pulse
event leaves you from resume state back
to the started state let's do the new
bow state or something like that and a
reason for this is from a system
perspective this stay state after on
pulse event and a certain event are the
same because the sets of actions if you
are allowed to do is the same and the
same is true for on stop and the created
state and last event is on destroyed
it's pretty straightforward it brings it
to destroyed state your activities
destroy it is going to be thrown away
and garbage collected well so let's make
our component life cycle where that's
super straightforward we take it with
life cycle observer interface it sends
the interface to get actual events we
add annotation and pass the events that
we are interested in you can pass
multiple events if you want some like
last step is to add ourselves as an
observer and we may have a potential
problem here
what if activity is already started at
this point does this mean that we are
going to receive on stop event and we
are not even we didn't receive on start
and our component probably is not ready
for this but we took care of it and we
bring them observer to the correct state
so what does this mean let's take this
example which I just discussed from a
teaching perspective on start and
uncreate already happen and after that
we add an observer
but observer will still receive on
create and onstart events like immediate
live and very very stirred so let's take
like one step further on resume same
situation resume states will bring
tourism State v we got the on resume
event in addition to on creator not
start a bit more interesting situation
on pulse in this situation we are in a
started state as well as we learned so
we bring the observer to the car a
correct state which is started so this
similar situation as we had one minute
ago absolutely receive on create and
don't startle it and that's it so we
don't have a problem and just Scott so
how to get this magical lifecycle object
we have this interface which is super
simple but this probably doesn't help
much right now and the extra question is
who are lifecycle owners out of box and
answered in this question is support
library fragments and support activity
but unfortunately this is true only in
bright future and right now we have life
cycle activity and latekka fragments but
at the point of one dot or release we
will merge our library to support
library so you don't have to use them
later and now I don't think about some
key differences in fragment and let's
echo observers so if you've been
following along you probably recognize
some similarities with the fragment API
in this as well so at this point we've
got these two different components which
one do you use well as the slides are
already spoiling for you this really
isn't an easy or an either/or question
one of these things doesn't necessarily
replace the other and here's why
fragments on one hand that everybody
knows and loves right our state fully
managed and recreated after either a
process death an activity recreation or
recreation of any host that you have the
fragment within
fragments manage views and also interact
with the navigation stack which are
things that are firmly out of scope of
what lifecycle observers are meant to do
instead lifecycle observers are meant to
enable more granular factoring of your
code whether you're in an activity or a
fragment they're stateless so that means
that they must be registered each time
the owner is recreated we're not going
to try to recreate these magically for
you they don't have any concept of
instant state that they carry around
with them so these are meant to be very
very lightweight so that you don't have
a whole lot of additional management
overhead and last there's no relation to
the viewer navigation management these
really are meant to be very tightly
scoped isolated components so they can
really help everyone it means that it's
a much simpler to integrate libraries
with your code as long as those
libraries have provided lifecycle
observer aware components it means that
you can break up those really large
fragment or activity classes to make
them much simpler to understand for a
reader and you can provide much more
granular guarantees around what
operations are valid at any given point
in time you can make it so that if an
operation happens then you're guaranteed
to be in a correct State when something
is called so lifecycle owner as already
introduced is just an interface anyone
can implement this this means that you
can improve testability by creating your
own you can create your own sort of
fragment like library implementations if
you feel so inclined but you can also
create composite life cycles life cycles
that span across other smaller lifecycle
definitions so you can answer questions
like is my app visible so this is a
really common composite life cycle that
many of you may be interested in it lets
you do things like session management to
track a particular session across
perhaps some sort of a flow or a series
of logging logged and versus logout
events and may help you with analytics
as well so we have the process lifecycle
owner as kind of a component that I
think a lot of you will be interested in
for this it's the composite lifecycle of
all the activities in your app so
there's no configuration changes to
handle because we're not going to be
dealing with those from these these the
process of lifecycle owner just stays
alive through the whole process but that
also means that you don't
at state rate restoration after process
death like we mentioned earlier so that
means that you don't have to handle
saving and restoring that state but at
the same time you need to remember to
re-register these process life cycle
based observers if that's something that
you're working with so many Android
components provide a lot of kind of deep
plumbing layers for things that you can
plug into and work with but a lot of
times we've kind of omitted the idea of
higher-level components that make use of
that plumbing so that you can just plug
play and go so I mean do we have
anything more high-level than the bear
events and states here maybe do let me
show you
great thanks ever look so so so nice now
you can observe a lifecycle is Val
define is the first-class citizen but
you still need to deal with these things
and we thought like okay there's some
common lifecycle problems that we should
be able to solve with this component so
we look at the problems that people are
having
and this wasn't probably the most major
problem may be seeing the untimely UI
updates is like when your activity
receives a callback but the activity is
already stopped it tries to start a new
activity and crashes or it tries to edit
fragment and crashes if an activity or a
fragment is stopped you really there is
no reason to update that activity right
you don't want to do that if the
activity happens to become visible again
then you want to do it so we realize
that this is a very common problem and
we wanted to solve this with a
higher-level component which we call
light data we look at the light data in
detail
it's actually an observable data holder
it just holds on to some information
that you can observe now the difference
between light Attah and your other
observers in data binding or extra or
whatever is that live data is life cycle
aware it knows about Android life cycles
and when you want to observe a light
data you can pass in this life cycle so
that it can manage your subscription
nice thing about light it is that you
observe and that's all you do so we look
at the usage example let's say we have
an activity receiver
like data from somewhere doesn't really
matter and then we call observable and
we are calling observe we are passing
this which is the lifecycle owner this
all you need to say I want to observe
this fly data within this lifecycle
which also means if this lifecycle is
gone I don't want to observe it or if
this lifecycle is stopped I don't want
to receive events and then once you do
this this all you do you don't need to
write on start on so we want Android to
want to more look like this you
initialize think is more like
fire-and-forget you initialize and you
are done
so let's look at what happens when our
activity starts observing that live data
so on create it called observe with it
live data is observable and as soon as
activity start it starts receiving data
changes so whenever the light its value
changes we dispatch that event back to
your observer inside the activity it can
also be a fragment let's say user
decides rotate the activity at this
moment so you know that the activity
will be stopped and what happens at the
same time the light Atta happens to be
updated if that happens we are not going
to tell the activity about this change
because there cannot be any reason for
you to update the UI because it's
already stopped similarly if the
activity's destroy it we will
automatically remove the subscription
because that activity is gone we know
about it there is no reason to keep a
reference back to that activity now we
say the activity was rotated so you know
that Android is going to recreate that
activity and then we are observing the
same light data back as soon as the
activity starts it's going to receive
lost available data so your UI is going
to have the data before it gets a chance
to draw so similarly I say user hit the
home button which means the activity
will be stopped again if the lighting
changes while the activity stops it's
not going to receive any event even if
the data changes we are not going to
tell it but as soon as if the user comes
back to the application
we will give it the last available data
so it's why we called live data is not
just a stream of events it holds on to
the data so that if any web server comes
it receives the last available value and
eventually the user backs out of that
activity and then we remove that
subscription you can also extend the
live data class when you accept because
my data provides two very handy
callbacks the first one is called on
active which means you have an active
observer and the other one is called on
inactive which means you don't have an
observer so don't bother changing your
value if it is something that you care
about you probably know what is an
active observer actor-observer is an
observer who's attached life cycle is
started or resumes so it's like a
fragment that's currently visible to the
user if the fragment is on the back
stack the user is not seeing it it's
stopped
so it's not active there is no reason to
do any work for that fragment we see how
we can take advantage of these new
callbacks so we are going to create a
new location live data class which
represents the location of something on
the device so we say this is an is this
data holds an instance of a location in
constructor we just get the location
manager from the system service there's
nothing fancy here and we have a
listener whenever the system server
sends us a new location we just call set
value on us this will you do there is no
lifecycle handling here you just call
set value and live data takes care of
handling the lifecycle and you may have
any number of observers it doesn't
really matter so we want to all right on
active right the way the very first
active observer comes we want to start
listen to the system service similarly
when the last active observer goes away
we want to stop observing the system
service now if you look at that location
live data cost we just created in the
previous example let's look at the
properties of that cost first of all it
is lifecycle area it knows when to start
it
when to stop itself you just don't need
to babysit it anymore it is self
sufficient like you started you forget
about it it can even be a single - like
all of these subscriptions are
automatically managed for you so if the
data is logically singles in your code
base you can make the live data is the
singleton so there's this thing where
like normally if you keep a reference
key and activity or a fragment from a
static context that will be a big no-no
but if you are using live data it is yes
yes because we manage the subscription
for you so you also don't need to
subclass it like that all the time so if
you just need an instance of it but you
already have the value you can use this
mutable live data class which comes
decide the library that has a public
setter but usually when you are using
this class internally you will have it
but the API you expose will just return
a live data because you don't want to
expose the fact that anyone can set the
value on it now when we were designing
these lifecycle components the live data
if we spent a lot of time to get rid of
one exception this fragment exception
[Applause]
we really wanted to say please normal
fragment transaction exceptions so
lightly to guarantee that if you
received an event you could run a
fragment transaction and to want to see
how we are making it part of the history
I wanna invite Adam back to explain it
to us
alright so anyone anyone who has
received one of these exceptions
realizes that it doesn't just come from
trying to do something when you just
completely stopped and you absolutely
know it these exceptions tend to come in
when you get into very intricate nested
life cycles so we wanted to make sure to
be very thoughtful about defining how
the lifecycle observer callbacks are
invoked and when so in a case like this
what happens you have defined to define
handler for the stop event so in the
container your activity on stop you want
to make sure that you don't get a non
changed event after the on stop has
happened but in but in order for that to
happen what needs to be true about when
we actually invoke all of the on stop
listeners and that are attached to these
observers so we have to define a really
strict order for this so as we go
through create and start and on resume
we know that we need to invoke the
lifecycle observers after the container
event happens so you know in your
observer that everything about your
lifecycle owner has been configured if
you check any state about it you know
that you're already completely in that
state but that means something really
special for coming back down the other
direction it means that when we when the
activity starts to become paused you
want your lifecycle observers to be able
to shut down anything that they're doing
before the activity does all of the work
to actually become paused similar for
stop and this is where this becomes
really important for the fragment
transaction exception you want to make
sure that you that you're recording that
you're fully stopped before the fragment
system goes through and flags everything
is being completely locked out so what
that means is that the stop event of
your light
cycle observer will always be invoked
before the activity on stop or before
the before the full stop event for your
container happens so this seems really
similar to some other libraries that
some people may have seen in the past
but can you talk about that yep yes so
when we create Europe terrible pattern
like nowadays this question is
unavoidable is it in another era Java
and answer discussion is yes because we
want to promote reactive programming
model especially when it comes to
relationship between your UI and the
stator phases here I you want to use to
react on the changes of the state so it
means that it's reactive programming
model but in the other hand
no because it's like Nicola we're out of
box as it gets mentioned and it's much
easier as many of you may know learning
curve curve of Eric's Java is super
steep and if you have a Android learning
curve and after that we add eric javelin
called curve on top of this it becomes
very hard to new people to start the
develop on our platform so we just can
just see 12 like oh let's go just learn
this that's it no so but if you already
learned
eric shell we don't you to don't expect
you to migrate from it to our solution
because you're ready pass this learning
curve your you and your coworkers are
comfortable with it fine
we are totally fine service but one
thing we ask you to do is to be sure
that you manage lifecycle every Java has
common approaches to solve this be sure
the uses and everything will be fine
but when you start when you start in
Europe we think that this model is the
best versus to start the project with a
live data
because it's simpler is faster it's
lightweight it's too well integrated
with a framework and if you feel like
you love reacting programming a lot you
want to bring it not only to relation
between UI and the state you want to
bring it to your business parts of your
application then you may consider
additional Forex jela because because it
gives it like more power and we know
actually help us to do that we have this
extension to our library which gives
give the possibility to create live data
from publisher and create publishers
from like that so this integration
should be quite smooth but I want to
highlight two key difference between
Eric Java and live data so as is already
said like that is a holder not a stream
so we have a reference to the last value
and observers immediately receive the
last really when they start subs starts
to observe live data another big
difference is a threading model as you
know i exac has very sophisticated
threading model it extremely powerful
but in most cases you probably don't
need it and will have everything on the
main thread and the reason for this is
we want to give you all these guarantees
about when we will notify you about
state changes so when we can't make do
this on a background thread we have just
one exception
we have a post value method which just
utility methods which trampoline value
from a background thread to the main
thread and set it there it's super
simple so quick summary of what we have
at this point the cycle events
observable pattern which respects this
length whether is one thing which is not
covered yet and this is how to handle
all configuration changes yep in 2017
like
almost nine years after Android the
first time released we still discuss
this question and this is a total edit
question and we hear it constantly from
new Android developers many of you
probably know what to do of it but let's
take a look at this oversimplified
example but still very vivid so you want
to show this information about user and
your activity and you want to make a
some web service request little use live
data to get this result it's super
simple
when request just started it's empty
when request request response is
received we put this is it to live data
as a value and later to well update our
UI I will notify activity and it's all
done everything it needs so what happens
if a change is going to be rotated yes
we're going to make it cold white and I
hope that you don't call the service
right into your activity but you
probably have some abstractions and you
need that does something like that which
goes to our network which go to any node
caching and persistent storages and this
all the separations are synchronous by
the net by nature so communication is
which components are a synchronous and
you probably don't want to make this
course twice anyway so what you want to
do is to cache this user data like in
our example and one of the ways today to
do that well one of a proposed way to do
it is a fragmented set retain instance
and each can rant about this for hours
unfortunately we don't have a time for
this today but I just say like the only
fact that you have to run fragment
transaction is terrifying for a lot of
people people go nuts
and another key another possible way to
solve this is the loaders but we don't
fit here well as well so we decided to
tackle this problem once again and
create view model so what is this in
order the
object associated with a fragment or an
activity but is retained during
configuration changes so its scope is
the kind of a logical scope of your
activity so what does this mean
let's see we have an access time and a
current moment and we can predict the
future and we know that activity is
going to be created and this means that
all constructions event is going to
happen during con created will request
via model for a first time we will
create it and after that this activity
just uses this via model very simple now
we predicted activity is going to be
rotated let's see what's going to happen
this our view model will receive will
receive event the spouse from stop and
destroy but when all these events are
cleared and your kilt is destroyed is
thrown away in garbage collected via
model survived it and the new activity
which was created in place the old one
uses the same old objects so you can
easily cache their live data as we want
source nothing else last case what is
going to happen if you have finished
call once again we will receive the
destruction length but this time the
model is available until on destroy
method during consistent local unclear
on this on it which in suffice you if
you have any currently running actions
or any resources it's time to close and
after that is going to be destroyed and
garbage collect as well so at the point
when your TV is destroyed it's not going
to be recreated again if your model is
gun as well so let's quickly make our
sample in the model so we start with
initiating new creation of view model
class we want to cache for user data we
create a filter that recreate our
attitude to needs to identify data
we create together for this and finally
getters extremely straightforward if you
already Requested the data we just
return it if we if the data is now ok we
request it from a web service in returns
it fine we have this code and our queue
so now we need to get this my data from
via model to get it we need to create to
get your model somehow so this is how we
do let's take a precise look on it
first of all we need to to get G model
provider object it's an object which is
associated with fragment or an activity
it knows how to get already existing G
models from it or how to create a new
one if there is no existence e model
after that we request our of our my
activity view model and later everything
is quite simple we get a user data we
observe it to update the UI fine so what
are the rules of usage of view model so
we model manage the data for the UI it
means that it speaks this business part
of your application to retrieve the data
so it may be a repository pattern or any
other pattern that you use it also its
forwards user modifications back to
these components another good case for
view model is acting as a communication
layer between fragments in one activity
and ease we'll speak about this bit
later but prior to this things that you
must let's do in your view models so
first of all you must not access views
and any other UI related entities result
that maybe are going to be created
during configuration change if you try
to use them you will ever use stale data
from where
leave them like that's going to live
finish bad and it's fragmented or
activities job to bind the data which
you will get from a view model with
actual UI six use buttons I don't know
what else and one more thing
well resources which sounds more
harmless like strings or drawable and
you may think I make a here
no they depend on current configuration
still state as well so yes it right now
you may have just one resource for every
configuration but later you will adds in
the same results for different
configuration it will easily forget
subjectivity model so and you may not
may not notice this your user but new
users will see the invalid UI and this
is just ugly and now it will speak about
inter fragment communication so I want
to talk about one of the one of my
favorite features about we model which
is communicating between multiple
fragments of the same activity also it
will screw the UI like this like with
Gmail on a tablet where on the left side
you pick an email and on the right side
it shows the contents of that email now
usually you will implement this as a
fragment on the Left which pick
something from the list another fragment
on the right which shows how to show the
contents of an email so that if you're
on the phone you can reuse the same
fragments but separate from each other
now if you ever try to write a UI like
this if you ever try to make these two
fragments talk to each other say pain in
the neck it's very very hard like you
need to create an interface but then
what if one fragment gets created before
the other one an activity needs to talk
to each other or like when the activity
is restored you don't really know which
fragment will be restored first it is
really hard to manage this same
well we can't really solve this very
elegantly using every model so let's see
so these two fragments actually want to
talk about a selected email right this
is what this the information they want
to share so let's put it inside the
v-model and we are going to call this
shared via model so it has a mutable
live data inside it should call selected
and it provides two-way simple API the
first one says said to select that email
to the CML and other one says get the
selected email as a live data so really
simple we model but now once we have
this let's go back to our fragments and
see how we can use this so inside the
content fragment which is the one that
wants to display the contents of the
email so it wants to know when the
selected email changes right so we are
going to go so we are already seen this
you can go to the mobile providers cost
and get the v-model providers of this
fragment but we actually want the V
models not from this fragment we want it
from our activity so all we have to do
is tell to get it from your activity now
it's going to return your V model in the
activity scope and I will say get for
the shell V model now the very first
time one of the fragments call this we
are going to create a new one when the
other fragment comes to life is going to
receive the same V model instance and I
know you do the same thing so this one
says get the selected email start
observing on it really similarly in the
selector fragment which was the one on
the left
my user picks an email we get the same
me model and then whenever the user
selects an email from the list we just
call the be models related method to
change the selected email now these two
fragments talking to each other without
actually talking to each other how does
it really happen so if we go back to our
UI so we have the selector on the left
the content of the right but if you look
at the details actually both of these
are talking to shared via model they
never talk to each other the video of
this solution is that
if you are on the phone they say one
fragment replaces the other one there is
no room for errors like the fragments of
severe model me models always that
nothing low crash they don't even care
the other one is there okay so this is
out of information there is like further
details about how these life cycles work
we really spent out of time to make this
like handle the most common use cases on
Android so we recommend you to first try
it out you can try it now and MAME of
Google call please check out all of the
architecture components these are things
that actually work very well together we
have an architecture guide which shows
you how to use these things together to
write a good application and also check
out our code labs we have code lab
sections at i/o that will give you a
first glimpse of how life cycles work
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]